so i take it we're just playing an hour
of straight up three plus zero
with trash talk mandatory i don't have
the
that much experience with like talking
at the same time as playing the trash
talk but uh
it will be fun yeah i agree i i also
don't have too much experience so
[Music]
i always struggle to decide what to do
in this complicated position
it's too complicated b3 wow
it's the go-to move i thought you would
go h4
yeah that's coming for when i i lose a
couple of games
yeah i've seen you do that let's go here
it even happened this morning okay
so the audio is fine you guys so let's
go knight f5
i've always been curious to try this
move against
okay so you're trying to take on g7 um i
should castle i guess
i don't know i'm not gonna confirm or
deny
i think you should take another you know
30 45 seconds i think in that position
all right so now i think g4 is the move
this is actually i don't know if this is
the thing
okay let's play d5 and hope we're not
getting mated
g5 d4
what's happening there yeah i've never
actually analyzed this but i've had this
in a bunch of like blitz games and stuff
so peter you had the experience here
bishop g4
you take on f6
okay the one thing i should not do is to
spend too much time against you
uh okay let's just play the one thing
you should do yeah let me try to capture
aryan's uh cam guys just one second
all right g5 was a very hard move to
find so i need to spend 35 seconds on it
okay queen h5 so digital f5 comes to
mind
i'm not threads so you know
yeah let's just do it okay
so the threat is stronger than its
execution i can give you that check on
you
one yeah you're welcome to do that i
will hide my king on age 8 i'm praying
but wait a minute yes let's try
to soften up the defenses here a little
bit
i mean just trying to figure out your
the tactics i mean honestly anything
you're trying to make work
you can't even reach number one here try
to
jump to the beautiful square on f3 i'm
gonna pretend i saw that but i mean
anything should work you you can't even
reach number one in your country so
like it's just small places norway so
anything yeah you win
it should be easy are you actually
streaming
uh right now yeah oh no no i'm not okay
i should be streaming more often but
last time i did was in november so
um yeah i gotta pick up the mantle again
yeah 95 was quite nasty
okay bishop b2 i provoked it you know
it's
a week in the d4s yeah of course of
course you saw everything coming
let's go here yeah now that is very
nasty stuff
okay i might take you up on that rook g1
move again
the rook has to join the party
crap okay mastering complex end games
oh now you're gonna crush me in the end
game okay
let's take f6 and games are totally my
strong suit
of course
why am i thinking let's go here there's
a lot to think about it's a complex
position
even without queens i'm going to make it
even more complex this is a typical
danielle movie
yeah it really is this is trying to
scare me
forcing a couple seconds off the clock
all right let's go out to a3 into c4
[Music]
let's take here
i felt good in the moment
start harassing the pawns where am i
even going with this
trying to trap my bishop
so i'm gonna try to hide it on a7 and
pretend it's okay
let's go here mm-hmm
square for a look
we need to calculate the variations here
yeah let's go here
thanks
now this is where stuff gets
real
you're dirty i know every little trick
right
every little trick
my god talk about dirty okay but that
wasn't
as dirty that was a nice one
ouch oh no still mate
yeah h4 was pretty strong and strong
there i just lost the threads
yeah that g5 square yeah
all right that was the swiss scam bit as
they call it
please don't take okay thanks yeah i'm
not i'm just going to quit
against you let's go
here and this is what all the cool kids
playing
okay the key in these situations is to
look up to pretend that i'm like
remembering theory even though i've
never looked at this
but you played kingston your whole life
didn't your whole life yeah
but you know the amount of files i've
created experience
yeah all right
it's funny because like i never studied
it as formally as i should have
the amount of bad positions i get yeah
but i guess with the king's indian you
just
uh i mean by getting the experience that
helps a lot
yeah it's such a resilient opening
typically yeah
it's always like plus two yeah and
there's always
resources with engines but uh now it's
not
as easy anymore yeah i noticed that
stockbridge 13 is like a lot more
realistic
it's the evaluation okay i'm going to
cost along now
that's what i like to see i have a great
kings indian bishop
i could only take my own yeah bishop g7
is amazing too
bishop is gonna win the game you mark my
words boy
wow
okay let's try to go here i'm gonna
stick that right in the hole
okay
what am i supposed to queen before okay
let's go here
you got to sacrifice something to come
to the game
yeah i need to take my own pawn on e5
like badly
yes like it's free rook free
rook okay let's open stuff up
you like to do that bishop
let's go here
that's actually a pretty cool move but
it does absolutely nothing
yeah i could see you play that move oh
totally snake
take oh god
okay what to do
all right whatever oh maybe i'll even
get a chance to open my bishop up
you're ignoring me you're really hurting
my feelings just wanting you to know
that
yeah only the queen is blocking it
all right here i think i might be losing
here
now it's my turn to open up
having sacrificed to one pawn i'm gonna
sacrifice the rest
okay i'll be greedy please
let's take
yeah find a couple more pawns maybe
here my bishop is open though that's
that's what's important here
i'm just gonna go queen f7 aren't you
i'm gonna be a coward and just try to
trade off those queens yeah
there's nothing i can do with my bishop
yes good game
all right let's try another one yeah the
last game didn't go well
uh okay let's try again but this time
the opening
the opening wasn't so bad so maybe i
should go for it again
i'm down i'm down if you are just hoping
you would go bishop b5 again
yeah no in your dreams
okay so what happens if i start with
this move
what happens well i'll take your knight
get this structure
let's give the check and pretend this
use
okay so de-94 very high level
calculation
all right get out of here
that's an annoying move
that's my one station in life yeah let's
do this all right perfect
okay now this is beautiful
it's a perfect pawn structure thank you
orifice
for the sub question always
is do i trade queens
yeah let's go bishop c-4 i'll let you uh
decide you know
should i hurt my pawn structure more
with bishop six oh god that is the big
question
let's do it and hope you will not give
me another endgame lesson
you know that's exactly what i woke up
thinking
okay now i'm transforming my double
pawns into another
oh you're here taking it rain
transforming
okay let's go
here still trying to
transform take it take it
come on yeah that ruins your pawn
structure further that looks like a
great idea
um okay let's go here
open oh i want to scrap bishop bishop
with rook b6
you see everything he sees everything
h4 now pretend that this is useful as
you say
yeah let's go here we're gonna follow
the end game rules here active king
can't hurt right
yeah that's what they say put the pawns
on the
dark squares now you're gonna regret
that move your pawns are going to be
weak
all on white squares i'm really
intimidated by that regrets
let's go here putting everything on dark
squares
just begging you to take on d6 problem
is even if you take the rook well
let's see what you do let's reroute
you guys what you want
see what you want is there anything that
can be done here
the answer is probably no yeah no i
think it's just a fortress
king is too active
right all right let's go here
yeah another one
what are you going to play this time in
castles
i like my position the last time so yeah
that did go very well
i don't see a reason to not go for it
again
okay so this time i'm gonna go h6
hmm this is how we're gonna play
hmm let's try h5
so positional of you you're welcome to
play g5 i like i
would love to play g5
okay let's try to be creative here yes
congratulations you have the f5 square
i'm very happy for you
i'm happy to yeah i mean let's go here
drawing magnus black pales in comparison
to having control of the f5 score
honestly
yeah it was just a a tiny bit different
type of position
right i would be a bit more scared if i
had this
just like magnus feels when he plays
rebecca harris all right let's go here
okay so i'm down on the clock that's not
okay it's all part of the planet
russell king is very safe when you play
g4 and put up on h5 sounds
yeah i'm gonna pretend i know all these
maneuvers
you know they're much better than me
you know you say that k form i think for
the tier one
what should i do now think for a minute
and 43 seconds
thinking way too much let's go up here i
don't know
if that's good hmm
i'm tripling and you can't triple so i
win the battle wow
amazing stuff going on
yeah i think i might resign after that
insight was shared okay let's get out of
there
let's get out yeah i'm just controlling
the most important c6 squares
nothing you can do yeah
there's a lot that you can do okay so
here
are you threatening to i'm too lazy to
even count
any of this stuff i'm gonna go here
yeah what can i do being greedy against
you is not a good idea
let's try to say that this is clever
or it could be very stupid i can respect
that kind of bravery
oh i've rendered the pawn what am i
doing
okay so what to do i don't see anything
what to do okay let's go back
oh you didn't see it oh my god minnie
three or how can i miss that arya come
on absolutely
oh my god
let's not plunder a queen i would
love that all right stick that in your
gut
you like one of us is going to blunder
at some point
okay let's go here it's so complex okay
i really want the end game
all right you got it you got it my man
let's take here oh you can do that
i saw that that was a positional
exchange sacrifice i thought first i
planned it but um
yes probably i didn't all right let's
take it
wow that's brave yeah
how to refuse it let's go here
yes sir yes sir
let's get some pieces into the game
taking away all the squares that's not
nice those bishops are just
like teeth boom
bishop perry is much stronger than the
rook that's the problem i'm checking
starfish on my phone one's nick
there we go all right don't check too
much
there we go starfish isn't good in the
king's indian gonna give up your bishop
pair
oh
[Music]
let's pretend i can do something with
that right finally then i get to g3 yeah
after a million years in
exile okay but what to do now
here
i feel like this game has been lasting
for like 18 years
just moving around finally okay let's go
here back
a little bit where you're going to take
that rook
what do we have afterwards though here
reflecting chests
galactic chess we'll just move around
and then he will flag me i know you
indeed indeed
this is my bread and butter sir
let's finally jump to the square wow
let's be greedy
ouch that's not nice of you down there
yes it's extremely nice i mean
i'm so stupid why did i put my king on
d2
oh mayday mayday
[Music]
i can see why people block me
[Laughter]
no it's all goods
it's my fault
high level chess by nerdetsky as usual
translates very well into classical
chess success
yeah for sure it's why i got invited to
total steel over grandma after
your master target yeah but you decline
this truck right it was
a little too weak for me yeah
you have nothing to do there
all right get all the residents for
breakfast
let's play daniel's style um what would
daniel do here
okay so let's go bishop g3
wow very brave
that comic i'm gonna be honest
knights are stronger than bishops right
so you can't
you can't take on g3
never forbidden okay this is a daniel
damn this is not what i had anticipated
okay so let's see take six takes takes
good good
i totally saw this yes okay
what would alireza do is what you gotta
ask yourself
now you're gonna out calculate me
i thought that was not possible i
thought so too but you know what do i
know i can't count when you dream big
everything is possible
let's try this yes yes yes of course
of course he sees it okay whatever
you take one g3 take on b6 second i have
to take okay i get two pieces how bad is
that
but i have some ideas yes you always
have ideas
no and they're always kind of bad
distance that's i had rook takes before
that was my idea
oh oh actually i didn't see that but i
there's
lucky but okay there are maybe some
lines
what you want sorry you're too
resourceful anyway
never quit it doesn't matter if it's bq
let's go here
hmm
that's slightly annoying just a tad
okay now queen b5
do we place solid
what is what is what does solid mean
out of my vocabulary
yeah that's the last thing you do play
solids
why am i spending so much time
another excellent question
oh
so explain to me please
what happens here wish i had an answer
um okay
there's gotta be some nice move here
let's hope not i think i found one
how about this one
tactical genius
this is where the fun begins ouch
yeah i think i shouldn't put my queen on
c7 there that was like yeah
the worst square yeah all these all
these forks and
yeah yeah okay let's play in himself
you give up on the king's indian game
yeah
no more i'm going to play more so i'm
going to play knight c6 here
let's be solid like oh g3
all right
structure you never know how to evaluate
always get your kings indian structure
anyway
yeah exactly i gotta play d65
all right ugh it's not really what i
want okay let's try something a little
bit different though
can i give you the c4 square though
maybe that was premature
let's give this guy a little tickle
queen b3 is not recommended here that's
a great move but in the end
it will be slightly better for you know
positional exchange sacrifice but okay
is there a room with someone
that's ship g4 is annoying um
yeah like it's actually hard to deal
with i think
uh f2 f3 would have been a pretty good
move all right yeah of course yeah
it would be a dream recommended by uh
galaxy drive and chess performance
it's incredible i don't have any moves
he sees everything
okay now we play slowly
you're not going to take a free pawn
yeah queen takes e4 is tempting
but i play more positional okay two
positional
that's you know it's not okay
there is some ideas here let's get this
guy
back
um and now i think the time has arrived
for this
now it's time to be really now it's time
to be greedy
but not too greedy don't get your hopes
up
i'm enjoying myself tremendously i just
want you to know that
it's not the nicest position i had
um i'm not known for my
killer's instinct in these positions
you're lying
let's come here
that is a sign of a great position
yeah pretty desperate position let's go
here
thanks nana lucky for the prime
i know i get a chance to believe it
should be too
now we're going to start mopping those
guys up okay
you get this one in game
all right what do we play let's go e4
bishop g4 was so annoying i'm sure i
should probably go bishop f3 or
something
yeah okay what do we play here
um all right
i'm gonna try this bishop d3 stuff
trying it recently online with success
yeah actually believe it or not it's
like the most seemingly innocuous move
but it's not so simple
[Music]
you're like you're full of it as usual
let's see now let's go here i think
that's the idea
i like that you're going to sacrifice
again something i don't know what and
where
but the hammer on i'm going to get it
done
but you should really consider the
details of the position
i should
and that's where my attack ends
i'm so tempted even though there's no
follow-up yeah take on f7 or e6
e6 is always the tempting phone for me
but i have a weakness for six pawns
no it's just too little like too little
play there
yeah sage somehow i didn't get mated
be careful it's okay
don't jinx yourself you're welcome to
take on h6 or play g4
let's go here
okay
i'll make it interesting how do we make
it
just
okay let's go here let's make it
interesting
very very positional two positional
always looking for some tricks let's try
this i always miss these moves
yeah that's a really nice move
yeah d takes c4d5 was not so
it's not so appealing was it
alright
give you a little choice
i don't like choices
i want to play the only move in the
position yeah exactly
choices are great okay
what now
i do this with a heavy heart
i'm i'm happy to see that move you gotta
be honest
no that was like that was really flat
but now
you will put your knight on e4 and just
push me
totally you know what i know you want me
to do it and i actually will
oh i saw that move yes
maybe it was stupid but i was just
trying to fool you but
uh i thought knight f4 knight d3 that
was the only thing i saw
this pro maybe better i don't know no
this is definitely better
it should be pretty good
how exactly do you win this though
yeah now i you are resourceful
it looks crushing and now we take
i take
i've been through worse
all right whatever yolo wow
so now you're gonna mate me yep that's
always the plan
is always the scheme
what a complicated position
yep
no threats
that's a nice move i have to
begrudgingly admit
but you always find resources that's the
problem uh
what do i do now
take some deep breaths okay
five
somehow
yeah i think you could have stepped back
when i played to g8 i accidentally
played knight g5 instead of knight f6
yeah yeah yeah probably
once again this is very sustainable in
classical chess
indicated okay so let's no but it's it
is part of the game
let's play c5
and this line
thank you fox okay let's go here
there's supposed to be some sort of
waiting moves here
this is the move
they always do this against indian yeah
there's a weird like pretending that the
knight is great on
c7 right exactly supporting b5
okay now i have to take
this
okay
not sure my knight will end up on c7
no maybe not anymore
oh thanks lily for the raid appreciate
it
okay do i look like somebody who trades
queens
yes no you don't thank you
that's for sure
okay what about this one
[Music]
to find something good here
please don't all right let's go here
a little intermediate move
let's just threaten to take a pawn oh i
gotta be greedy
yeah it's not a bad strategy
special before you want queen e3
xp3 oh we need three is also possible
thanks i was thinking when a3 actually
oh yeah queen a3 oh yeah yeah but
they're probably h3 was better
all right let's just yolo this
i don't think
this is what you want
not sure about it but uh it's definitely
interesting and it's going to suck some
time off with my clock
because i'm calculating some cool stuff
you always do
none of it really okay let's do it
whatever i knew you were going to take
i cannot resist ever thanks player for
this stuff
okay
oh god damn it
that one is annoying for sure i just got
to refocus the attacking resources
just trying to get my own free pun
pass h6 aren't you
let's try to be extremely tricky and
hope i don't
understand that is a nice one
i see what you want well i have to
hmm not good i don't know
is there any alternatives i gotta try
maybe this one
just as i lose the game well done that
was that was good
you know it's so difficult to beat you
just one game so it's uh achievement
all right so you're gonna play with
berlin
i'm gonna play bishop a4 oh you always
play this i don't wanna get mated
now you're in my territory
now you're in my territory
let's go here
it's funny because the first time i
faced this with was with black against
ray robson
one of two times i played the berlin
that's where i learned about it
in classical or yeah us us championship
2016.
and i won that game but i was much worse
than the opening
yo so it's like an ironic
yeah just remember it was f5 somewhere
but that could make sense yeah this is a
good line
but no looking at this for a bike
but it's a long time ago now
logical logical
okay well we got a liquid data
let's take it
very positional yes
at least i'm not mated yet
yup i'm trying to decide whether to take
on f7
all right fine
i think maybe a little something here
i'm not going to complain about my
position
you're going to take it stoically get
some air for the king can't hurt
i'll get you some air don't you worry
that's kind of move that like looks good
and i'm not sure it's necessary
i thought you would go queen e5 like
trying to get yeah
that would be a typical daniel move you
know
i always have to think what danielle
does
daniel must sacrifice a piece here did i
always attack twice a piece
i know what you're thinking about i'm
gonna have six
no it's good it's like vicion and
when they were annoying at the press
conference
like no i was thinking what to eat
tonight
i actually watched it some days ago i
was it came like randomly on youtube
i was there's like two of them and then
the other one was like
like he keeps getting asked the same
question he's like uh like
i don't get why i don't understand
english like he understood the same way
and we're like from vishy
[Laughter]
that's just amazing
yeah magnus has like he's like tries to
just be extremely greedy
oh you you are going to regret the day
you were born
i'm just counting the pawns that's all i
did keep counting
i'm not sure how to i'm actually gonna
go here weirdly enough i don't know this
looks awkward but i think it creates
some tricks
yeah that makes make it sense
rookie is not so clever as i thought i
was hoping for that
let's go maybe d6 was
this is what you want
can only avoid the repetition
alright let's refocus
here bring the bishop back to life
bring it in boy
ouch oh i actually did see if it should
be fine
okay how do i follow up on that is the
key question
let's be more easy
ah damn i i knew there was something and
i didn't know what it was
no oh you're too fast down yeah
you're way too fast sorry that was
ridiculous
all right let's go back to old old
habits indian
yeah i spent too much time i guess when
i took your rook i don't know
because at some point i had like three
seconds more but right
but i had all these checks and like all
these yeah
yeah so i guess i had to be oh crap
that was not good
damage control
let's pretend this is clever very
positional
keep it a c5 square but i
yeah somehow this is okay for mike
yeah probably b5 was
okay best fiance
look into
all right can't resist these kinds of
moves
superficial as hell yeah my bishop
is amazing on a1 the most powerful piece
ever
indeed indeed
all right i know why but this seems
vaguely good
h5
just to make you think that i have some
idea
oh i'm asking for it yes you are
i will deliver
something i can promise you that
what exactly it'll be i don't know yet
let's go
that's not nice not at all scary chuck
and what i'm just supposed to take this
oh okay that doesn't work
let's go here
only you can defend these positions
i don't know
i want to find something nice but
right now i can't really find just have
to hope for some
show off right exactly
you know i have a weakness for those
don't you yeah
play for the beauty of the game
yep
there's definitely some cool ideas
take your time i'm trying to like
find a clinical one i think this one's
all right
let's see carlsbad
all right this one
the main move and in your style so right
exactly i have to play it
g5 this is all that i know
that cool people play don't they
can i do this
you you would not insist for a second
okay
[Music]
okay
um
h6 was way too nasty yeah i should play
94 first
oh yeah yeah okay now
again it's the same problem
that i always have
where is it you're definitely enjoying
yourself here with me i'm greatly
enjoying myself but i'm not but
but i'm legitimately not seeing the
killer
should be there it has to be there maybe
i should take another minute to find it
please do
i'm sure i would i'm gonna be lame as
hell
yes sir you want me to take on f5
in your dreams
what was that you're still welcome to
take on f5
oh i'd love to just start on the next
move
um now i'm enjoying myself
uh
keep getting distracted by these ideas
excellent
so
down for one last one sure let's go all
right
one car
i'm pretty predictable at this point
right
you forced me
it's pretty funny you know i had this
game in sweden um
four years ago and i didn't take on a7
but i think that was the right one
oh really this is actually you actually
had this yeah i didn't take on i7
because i thought it would be dangerous
but then the
computer was saying that taekwondo 7 was
supposed to
wow that doesn't happen in this game but
it's very reassuring though maybe i'm
full of [ __ ]
for me because it's only because
right
yeah that's what i was worried about
yeah
okay bring this guy in
got to preserve the night
running too much time no it's
a perfect time
okay
where's the bamboo stick
i don't know about that okay let's go
here
i can't hear you too well oh sorry can
you hear me now
yeah perfect i said it was only move i
think
yeah 92 there was some stuff there yeah
92 looked more scary i guess i have to
need the e2 square for my queen or
something to
to defend this move i didn't see
but maybe i can still play queen too
yeah i just kind of have to bail out
into this position
oh nice one
we'll see it's never over against you
yeah yeah
fair enough okay
hmm
[Music]
too many of these
wow you know what's happening next time
is increment
then the the real chess player will
emerge victorious
so oh well thank you thank you
that was a lot of fun yeah yeah
thanks for inviting me of course another
time
two hours and increment next time i'm
totally down
uh it's yeah but it is it is part of the
game though
i appreciate it um there's plenty of
people who
disagree but uh
i'll let you enjoy your evening thank
you ariane i really appreciate it let's
do this again soon
see you all right good games bye